Ben & Jerry's
okay Ben & Jerry's recently has taken a
very strong position with black lives
matter and if you look at their
Instagram post one after another after
another you've been seeing what they've
been talking about Josh your thoughts on
this okay I got a couple of thoughts
here obviously I can go in and I can
talk about defund the police and how
stupid that is but let me move on to
what I think they are doing wrong here
when you are a brand when you're a brand
you're an ice cream brand and now you
are weighing in i've now some good fact
check me here i don't know this to be
the case I'm assuming Ben and Jerry's
probably a publicly traded company okay
I think that you have a responsibility
ability to the people that have bought
into your brand to not do anything that
is purposefully divisive or it can take
away from essentially the bottom line in
the revenue and your brand beats so say
they come out and they take aside now
what have you done you've alienated half
the country and we've seen what's what's
happened to that with canceled culture
and I'll say this on both sides because
I hey I've played into canceled culture
of Starbucks okay so I like I think it's
it's stupid it's ignorant for the CEO to
do something that's gonna be divisive no
matter what I think of their idiotic
message response before they went out
and took this position you don't think
they had a conversation internally and
said alright guys here's what's going
down here's where here's the direction
we want to go as a company you don't
think they had that conversation I don't
think they took it to their stockholders
okay I'm just saying internally so they
knew what they were doing number two
number two marketing we're talking about
Ben & Jerry's right now number three do
remember when Nike came out and
supported Colin Kaepernick they said
they had they they made a decision all
right guys we're nine buys Nike tennis
shoes we could say nothing we can say
something we can support the police we
can support the flag we can support
where do we stand where do we stand as a
company and what did they choose what
did they choose Peabody
they chose cap and what happened to
their stock prices they made like 5
billion the next day or next tell me why
who's their base okay I'm just but
what's your people that buy you're going
with this Ben and Jerry's they're not
stupid idiots they're not they're just
Valley walking into this mess they knew
what they were doing we're talking about
Ben and Jerry's I don't know if they're
a publicly traded company or not but I'd
like to see what happens let's see what
happened to their stock prices let's see
who wins okay so this company I think
they were founded in 78 I don't know
what the year is it's a founder Ben and
Jerry they're Jewish
they're liberal and one guy's name is
big green fields something if you look
at the and and the current CEO was a guy
named matthew matthew something
the founders names are Ben Cohen and
Jerry Greenfield okay but go what your
1978 yeah I was right so go back and put
Ben and Jerry's CEO I think the guy's
name is Matthew something Matthew
McCarthy okay there you go
they were found as over linked in
Vermont that was just there like a
couple months ago we got a private tour
of the entire place really unique please
you have ice cream yes we did absolutely
with I'm a haagen-dazs guys to work it
out here's the thing that I don't care
okay if if they want to do that and if
that's where they stand and a majority
owner majority of the company the owners
are who Ben and Jerry they want to do
that guess what they're liberals and if
you look at if you go a judge I go down
and type in on Ben no no go all the way
up go all the way up and click on the
call Chi in Wikipedia buddy go no go go
on Wikipedia kiyah vagina click on Ben
Cohen go to Ben Cohen the bottom-left
founding look at bank one right there on
the founding click right there bottom
left on the page you're on bottom right
there bang :
founded click on him yeah call good
university be a March 18 1951
69 years old American businessman okay
right there Bennett Bennett Cohen is an
American businessman and what active
activist okay so guess what he's staying
true to his vision of what he wants to
do I don't have a problem with
doing it why because the founders are
taking this position because Matthew
couldn't do this without the approval of
the founders now for sure having said
this let's go to a different I'm gonna
give you a complete different
perspective yeah let's set them aside
what they're doing all good no problem
you do it but go to a company that wants
to take a position like this where the
founder is dead okay so let's just say
Apple were to take this position job
that's not here Tim Cook has are taking
a position of a thing that Jobs would
never do Jobs was famously known for a
guy who had 40 billion dollars in cash
and he never gave a penny to charity and
they hayden afford why don't you give
the charity I don't want it's our cash
jobs wasn't a big charity guy and he got
a lot of criticism Ford right Tim Cook
is slightly different but I'm gonna give
you a different angle
why didn't I ki take a position of cap
why did they do it if they're sitting
there and they're bored here's what
they're thinking about in every family
one of your parents if you make a
comment you're walking on eggshells with
them in your family you may say if I say
something sensitive my dad is like this
he'll snap immediately but my mom is
more what forgiving yes or no does
everybody have something like that would
you say that as well yeah somebody you
probably your dad you know the king of
your dad is going to be different okay
cancer God you have to go to death this
guy's you find out what I just said
right now watch this whenever a site is
more sensitive and you walk on eggshells
you don't want to piss that site off but
you don't mind doing something that the
other side's gonna be more easier to
deal with for example let's just say a
parent is involved please two kids okay
one kid you can you know betray him a
little bit but he'll what he'll forgive
you you can spend more time with his
kids and I'm the dad or not you got kids
he's guy can spend more time with his
kids and you pissed off at me but you'll
forgive me but if I spend too much time
with you he won't talk to me for a year
so guess what
he's more sensitive than you are Nike
made the decision saying we have
republic
we have Democrats which side is more
forgiving if we go the other side our
Republic is more okay if we go
that's a good event the Democrat you
need and there are Democrats more okay
if we go on the Republican side I
guarantee the board cetera and say
Republicans will forgive you
Democrats won't forgive you and they
made a decision to go there so when you
think about real business you have to
think about the sensitivity sides of
both sides well I say anything if you're
an ice cream because they made um
billions by making a position like that
and Ben and Jerry you think Republicans
are not going to be Ben and Jerry
because the position they take they
could care less they're gonna go ed and
Ben & Jerry's they're not gonna do that
but they just gained a whole level of
publicity and an audience that like we
weren't getting amazing marketing all
personally but it doesn't have to do
with the way you're thinking amazing
marketing it's not about that it's more
it's bigger than that okay it's it's
much bigger than that there is a side
that is more vocal than another side and
people naturally want to avoid conflict
and the avoidance of conflict today you
don't want to have conflicts with the
black American community with the
African American community that's simple
what it's at right now you probably
don't want to play that card today so
let me let me point something out here
Dan Kathy the president the founder of
chick-fil-a he was willing to go against
the LGBT community obviously it like
blew up into this whole like he stood
firm and fast on his biblical principles
there okay and obviously you saw I mean
there were lines for flipping a mile but
what's interesting when it came to the
BLM he actually flipped positions now I
don't know what this says except that
maybe he's a lot more concerned but you
actually see him in a video that he did
with Lecrae you actually saw him take a
totally different stance than I thought
that that that he would and it's kind of
interesting from somebody that is a
really strong conservative that Dan
Kathy would actually flip put position
so I don't know if that means that he
thinks that this is a much more
sensitive topic it could hurt his market
share more than the whole is chick-fil-a
yeah yeah yeah
the answer why dave chappelle once said
it in one of his comedy bits he goes
it's no secret blacks and chickens are
quite fond of one another this was Dave
Chappelle quoting Dave Chappelle our
show just got canceled no not this is
Dave Chappelle
[Music]